on voit bien qu'il y a des des fractures
qui commencent à être consolidés donc
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez
rencontré vous les propriétaires à un
moment pas du tout
vous les connaissez
non c'est pas notre rôle nous c'est
vraiment la prise en charge de l'animal
c'est ça après une enquête de police
tout à fait on dit on va on va vous
raconter le récit dans un instant
il risquerait jusqu'à 5 ans
d'emprisonnement oui parce que c'est 4
ans mais il peut y avoir des
circonstances aggravantes notamment si
on est propriétaire et puis en fonction
de votre plainte qui est pour acte de
cruauté mauvais traitement infligé sans
nécessité et privations de soins il peut
y avoir de multiples circonstances
aggravantes ça peut monter effectivement
à 4 ou 5 ans et 50000 euros d'amende
voilà ça c'est la peine maximale qui
pourrait être infligée aux propriétaires
du chien alors on va revenir sur les
propriétaires du chien est-ce que pour
vous déjà 5 ans est-ce que vous trouvez
que c'est c'est
si ce qu'il faudrait pour moi c'est que
ces peines soient réellement infligées
parce que là on a vu vous souvenez de
l'affaire du rappeur qui qui a été
condamné à des jours amende entre
guillemets là maintenant je pense qu'il
faudrait sévir la loi existe les peines
sont là il faudrait qu'un jour elles
soient appliquées c'est de la
maltraitance animale c'est pour moi
c'est exactement comme de la
maltraitance sur un homme donc ça mérite
sanction alors on va vous raconter toute
l'histoire une fois de plus parce que
c'est vrai que c'est une tic-tocqueuse
aussi hein qui a signalé il a fait
vendredi dernier donc les équipes de la
Fondation assistante aux animaux sont
contactés par la bague d'Argenteuil ce
que vous dites dans le Val-d'Oise
et mettez par l'image que nous renvoie
cette petite boule recroquevillée nous
découvrons un petit être en très mauvais
état général maigre les et malnutri
boiteux par des par des pâtes fracassées
un corps parsemé de blé et des
cicatrices de cigarettes et d'acide
celle qui a révélé la faire c'est une
tiktokeuse qui s'appelle betka qui a
publié plusieurs vidéos dans laquelle il
explique l'histoire et assure avoir tout
fait pour récupérer l'animal regardez en
gros votre French McQueen son chien son
chiot et c'est son mec et elle elle fait
rien il le frappait
à la ceinture des coups de béquilles
un bébé ouais il le sortait jamais
[ __ ] il faisait bonne figure câlin
tout ça mais [ __ ] c'est du faux
comment tu peux créer un Instagram à ton
chien alors que tu le maltraites et le
mettre dans des clips alors que dans la
vie de tous les jours le chien il va
mourir si je serai pas intervenu il
serait mort il serait mort
oui donc c'est cette petite tokyoogie
alors elle parle de rock et Roca donc
qui habite à Argenteuil depuis le mois
de juillet qui ont eu le chien au mois
d'octobre ils ont acheté à des éleveurs
600 euros ils l'ont appelé Texas il
avait donc deux mois
apparemment l'éleveur les a prévenu
qu'il ne pouvait pas détenir le chien
sans avoir de permis c'est ça mais
l'info l'aurait été donné après l'achat
c'est ce qu'ils disent absolument ils
ont eu le chien et je vais vous quand
vous voulez je vais vous donner leur
version qui s'est passé et eux estiment
qu'on ne les a pas prévenu avant des
règlements je précise simplement que
maintenant aujourd'hui en France les
règlements il suffit de regarder quand
on achète un chien il suffit de lire le
nom du chien et on a le règlement mais
eux dit ça voilà